why do you think teachers are going on
strike pupils here in Leicester have
been learning why their school will be
closed staff striking here have the
support of their head teacher
this is about the education profession
we have to stand up and do something
about it otherwise nobody will want to
become a teacher going forward but for
parents it means making other plans is
it going to cause a child care issue for
you if you're honest yes they need
someone with them at home I don't blame
the teachers they need more pay
thousands of schools will be affected
after talks between unions and the
government broke down we want to resolve
this dispute I think the unions all the
other all four unions want to resolve
this dispute but you know going on
strike is not the way to conduct a pay
negotiations in a modern economy
particularly when it means disrupting a
child's education and disrupting the
lives of families up and down the
country Rachel who works in a special
school in Cheshire has found the
decision to strike difficult but says
she needs to be paid more
I think that he'd need to put a message
out to the government that we are have
had enough we haven't got much money and
we need to make sure we've got bills to
pay and make sure that we can pay bills
and still have a life
this Secondary School in Birmingham will
be partially open year 11s who have
gcses soon will be in year tens like
Luca and Aya won't we get a break-off
score but then that may affect our
learning but we've got online classes so
not too much to worry about really but
Aya is more concerned it is quite a
shame that we don't get the education
that we need
are you worried about your exams next
year it is definitely a worry and this
is just the first in a series of planned
strikes that will see classrooms once
again fall silent
Becky Johnson Sky News Birmingham
and it's not just teachers striking
tomorrow rail workers across the country
will strike again to Bringing large
parts of the rail network to a
standstill on Wednesday Friday and
smaller strike action is also due at the
weekend bus drivers will also strike in
parts of London
let's have a look at other Industries
University workers Civil Service
employees and legal workers will also
take industrial action this week
in Scotland teachers are continuing
their 16 days of strikes which is due to
last until next week and perhaps most
disruptive will be the teacher strikes
in England and Wales tomorrow 23
000 schools in England and Wales will be
affected by this industrial action the
Neu expects well over 150
000 teachers to walk out the union says
it's had an extra 40 000 teachers sign
up since strikes were announced two
weeks ago